hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the baby food challenge
with Wayne and Jessica say I hey guys
say hi welcome to the baby food
challenge with Wade and Jesse alright
guys hi
great ok so what we're gonna do is we
got a bunch of baby food that's been the
labels have been removed but the answers
are on the bottom so I got this from the
idea of the game grumps livestream where
we did pretty much the same thing we're
gonna get baby food we're gonna look at
it we're gonna open it smell it try to
guess what flavor it is and then take a
big ol spoonful and see if we were right
can we get the first baby food please
thank you lovely uh thank you the
assistance the soon to go guys you've
already cracked it open so I'm assuming
oh you got the jar ha ha ha ha I can
smell it from here
holy crap oh let me give a whiff of that
ooh smells like my first thought to be
stupid why beef stew carrots maybe
potatoes ok carrots and potatoes beef
stew ok did you already start eating or
something ok I heard I heard smacking
lips over on my red bottoms up
it's good give us some input here come
on give us some input is Carol Channing
your guru good ok what like every church
pew its mucus feed bakley's beautiful
religion whew ah makes sense some babies
dewd free puke fish okay so look on the
bottom or was it mixed vegetables and
chicken dinner I'm not bad I can't be
that bad it was worth take something
just so good actually I think it's like
some banana some banana yeah you be like
a fruit cup banana and apples bananas
apples up there like two or three fruity
ones here and then the rest are all beef
chicken vegetable dinners maybe sweet
potatoes maybe some apples I'm not sure
okay
like a little left over that's not bad I
can't I can't place it face of it banana
plum and grape that was delicious who's
really good I like that one
why are you going to him the good ones
challenge really go guys
really hope it's what it is I'm tasting
it I really hope it's a speech in here
somewhere
it's another fruity one sweet potato
corn
oh I'm here oh oh
anyway thanks so much for that what do
you think of it I don't I take you to
hurry up Oh God oh that is straight-up
dog food is he gonna live with that let
me finish new potatoes I get I I knew
there was a good reason why we have them
handing it out to us more than what I'm
using baby
oh god no don't puke don't puke nope you
got camera
Telegraph room smiling hello again I
don't play anymore
I guess I'm gonna share something
suffering here Oh Jesse oh so bad haha
I literally always vomited yeah me too
oh my god oh wow oh wow he's like it are
you like what is wrong with you wrong
with you okay yeah oh I already looked
at what it is Oh what is it sweet
potatoes and Turkey
oh that should have been delish you like
sweet potatoes and chicken she got like
horn co-speaker dozen corn that's what
yet okay well it's like smells like
tomato sauce is it
that's probably worse yeah seems like a
tomato broth all right here we go
bland ah not as bad as that one though
not as bad as our cuz I literally have
trouble keeping yours dad we only had to
do three what is wrong with her didn't
you actually have a story Jessie where
you ate baby food until you were like 12
years old okay okay wait well what ages
eighth grade uh thirteen oh yeah good
for you congratulations that's why he's
winning at the shows and this one was
chicken and rice oh boy okay ones are so
bad so bad that's all I've had is meat
oh that's like applesauce that might be
the apple the straight-up applesauce at
my own I think that's literally Apple so
what is happening with this challenge
wha-ha-ha-ha-ha like apples oh yeah
oh why he's up against one and he hates
it
Apple meal apple cinnamon and oatmeal oh
we got some of that that sounds great
yeah please pass that down oh that is
delicious
no straight-up delicious merge the
texture they got me at first
dammit Oh yummy okay oh this smells
fantastic that is some kind of fruity
concoction from heaven that's not bad
Sally I've get lots of you Oh
all right what is it I don't know Apple
they do a banana and each of them know
I'm doing exactly Apple strawberry
banana
okay strawberry to be jumbo got okay
good enough all right this one looks
like straight straight green giant jizz
that's got a hint to Peas yeah it's got
a berry that's all he's something that's
Peas that's a whole lot of peas carrots
peas it peas baby lettuce jdbc he's
heard you also have peas I really hope
my so bad look
well that's not Peas not bees
I don't know what that is but that's not
bees are P snow peas little pretty think
it is Jessie you gotta go ahead jesu
what's here guess my receipts better
than coming out of the Green Jones -
clang gasps that's real to be honest
what is it what do you think I think
well there's no way that's two minutes
spinach okay maybe some Spanish green
beans all like oh that was bad bad our
green beans are literally my like
arch-nemesis and uh Thank You Janelle e1
let's move I picked up eating your
girlfriend so anyway that was the baby
food challenge Thank You Jessie and Wade
for trying that out with me how was it I
like some of it yeah yeah some of it
babies don't have it all that bad don't
eat the meat ones yeah for some reason
when they try to feed babies meat it
doesn't work out too well literally I
think that's exactly how they make dog
and they just mix it in with a little
yeah all right so either way thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
all for joining us if you want to see
more challenges in the future let us
know what you would like to see and
check out some of the other challenges
that we've done we also got Matthias
Sheldon's coming up real soon
yes whisper challenge part 2 all right
thank you guys again and as always we'll
see you in the next video bye bye
would you please feel the lipstick
hahaha mizzle that's your stupid name
yeah